a show of unity from the us and three
allies whose spheres of influence span
the indo-pacific a region under pressure
on many fronts from an increasingly
assertive china
cheated the four of us committed that
unilateral change of status quo by force
will never be allowed in any region
especially the indo-pacific and that the
free and open indo-pacific is ever more
relevant today
in coming to asia pacific president joe
biden has pursued a focus begun by his
predecessors despite the unfolding
crisis in europe at the same time we're
navigating a dark hour in our shared
history
the russian brutal and unprovoked war
against ukraine
has triggered a humanitarian catastrophe
this is very important for joe biden to
demonstrate to the world that the
commitment to the region is unwavering
this commitment has been going on for
several years going back to the obama
administration but there has been there
have been doubts over the last few
months given the ukraine invasion but
the failure of india to condemn russia
and its continuing close relationship
with moscow shows some of the strains
within this diverse group china's
growing economic muscle also makes it
harder for neighbours to stand up to it
for asian allies like japan supporting
the quad is complicated by the fact that
china is its biggest trading partner and
it seems going too far in antagonizing
beijing can have real consequences in
terms of business as australia has found
to its cost
australia has felt the impact of
punitive trade restrictions for its open
criticism of beijing in recent times but
australia's newly elected prime minister
anthony albanese promised to continue
robust support for this group which is
still relatively new i think they're
feeling their way
the quad is i think quite experimental
and to this point i don't think that the
four partners have really worked out um
how they're going to collaborate
after his shock remark that yes the u.s
would intervene militarily against china
if it attacked taiwan biden had to
answer repeatedly that no this wasn't a
change in the us's long-standing
position on china or taiwan
he leaves tokyo hoping this gathering
will be remembered more for diplomatic
harmony than the controversy stirred by
seemingly undiplomatic language rob
mcbride al jazeera tokyo